Ladies and gentlemen, thank you for standing by and welcome to the Etrion 2020 year-end report.
At this time, all participants are in a listen-only mode. After the speaker's presentation,
there will be a question and answer session. To ask a question during the session, you will need
to press star 1 on your telephone keypad. If you require any further assistance, please press star
0. Please be advised that today's conference is being recorded. I would now like to hand the
conference over to Marco Antonio Northland, CEO. Please go ahead.
Thank you, Michelle. I would like to welcome you to Etrion's 2020 fourth quarter and four-year
operational finance update call. I'm here today with Cristian La Puebla, our Chief Financial
Officer, Martin Orebic, our Chief Investment Officer, and David Ramirez, our Director of
Accounting and Reporting. I will start today the call by taking you through the corporate
overview and operational update and outlook for our businesses. Then we will go through
our 2020 results, and finally, we will open the calls for questions. As a reminder, a replay of
this call will be available today on the company's website with a copy of the presentation that we
will offer and refer to throughout the call. For those of you using our webcast facility,
the slides will automatically advance during the presentation.
If you turn to slide 2, there is a disclaimer on which, during today's call, we will make
forward-looking statements that are subject to various risks and uncertainties described
in the second slide of this presentation and in our 2020 management discussion and analysis and
press release, all of which are available on our website. Please see these documents
for additional information and factors that may impact these forward-looking statements.
Please now turn to slide 3. Etrion has a dual listing in Canada under TSX
and under the ETX symbol, as well as OMX in Sweden, as well under the ETX symbol.
We have 57 networks operational, 45 networks under construction, all fully funded,
which are all in Japan. We exited 2020 with a strong cash flow position of $8.9 million
of non-restricted cash. The main shareholder is the Lundin Group with 36%, and second is the
highest is the management with under 6%. Our market cap as of March 12 is $104 million.
Please now turn to slide 4. Let me highlight to you the most important matters that impacted
our 2020 results. Firstly, and most relevant from the point of financial results, was the
completion of the sale of the immediate 60 megawatt investment rights, collecting an
aggregate amount of $41.6 million. This was a terrific outcome for a project that was still
in the development stages. As a result of this transaction, we were able to
get ready to pay our corporate bond in early 2021. Very excited about this outcome.
We also completed the sale of PV Salvador assets in Chile. Although this asset has
been completely written off, we're able to collect additional $3.3 million in sales proceeds.
On the operational side, the operating assets deliver in all three key metrics
with a four-year guidance in the mid-level.
And then on the 45-megawatt Niigata solar project under construction,
it's on a schedule and budget. Modules are being delivered on site. We're first stage
of installation underway. We'll take a bit more, we'll talk a little bit more about this
project in a few minutes. We funded the escrow as of December with the proceeds of the MIA projects,
as I mentioned earlier, to repay the corporate bond in 2021. The last item that we also, I think,
was very important to highlight in 2020 that we engaged a financial advisor for the sale of the
next slide. If you turn to slide six, I would like to update you on the sales process. As you know,
we made a decision last summer to engage a financial advisor to assist the company
address the many parties interested on our operating assets in Japan.
We hire Mitsubishi Morgan Stanley, the team based in Tokyo, to assist the company manage this process.
This whole process was broken down into three phases. The first phase, which started in the
offers on the third quarter of 2020. As part of the phase two, we shortlisted a selected few
to obtain binding offers that were then selected and obtained to start the phase three.
So, in phase three, we selected one consortium for the potential sale of the four operating assets,
and we are targeting to sign the stock purchase agreement before the end of April.
This transaction, obviously, is subject to approval,
and closing is expected approximately by the end of June.
For the Niigata project, which is under construction, we selected a different consortium,
and we're also targeting to sign the stock purchase agreement before the end of April.
This asset also will be subject to shareholders approval, which is expected
approximately by the end of June. So, under current structure, because we are
selling substantially all the assets, it is the reason why we need to go through the
shareholders approval, which we should schedule shortly, and then that's what we're expecting
to have the financial close sometime in June. Management is confident agreement will be signed,
but obviously major obstacles remain to be resolved over the next few weeks.
There is a possibility of some delays, but we remain optimistic that they will be able
to meet the objectives as we have outlined above. On the next slide, if you could turn to slide A,
it shows you the graphical location of all the projects that are currently for sale that we're
going through the process, and I'll provide you an update on where we are with these five projects.
The first one, if you go to slide nine, our existing operational assets continue to deliver
strong results. Although we had less than hours than expected,
the systems performed have significantly met the objectives as we outlined in the guidance for the
2020 year. We were able to reduce the O&M cost as well as we were able to improve the EBITDA.
If you go to the next slide, I would like to update you on one particular situation regarding
one of the plans that we have in the four operating assets. During January and February of 2021,
the Mississauga area experienced the worst snowstorms recorded in the past 25 years.
As a result of the storms and freezing temperatures, two of the four solar assets
for Mississauga had some damages. The production of electricity was partially interrupted,
and they will be interrupted until the damages are repaired. The solar project company has
property and business interruption insurance, which we are currently discussing, that should cover
both the cost of damage and also any revenues that may have been dropped as a result of these
damages. We expect to have these parts fully restored by June of this year.
Let me now – one thing, actually, before I go to the next slide, I just want to highlight that
the team in Japan has done a fantastic job in managing this situation. As always, they have
been terrific, providing very quick solutions and being very proactive in resolving any problems
that we have on site. Let me now go to a
As you may recall, if you go to slide 12, this project is scheduled to reach COD. COD,
as you may recall, is when we actually begin generating revenues. By Q4 2021, this project
has very strong, very rich economics with a payback of two years from COD. And we own
100% of this project. Obviously, this is one of the projects that is on the sales process.
The project has a very attractive project finance through a corporate bond, a green bond,
that we did in 2019. And it has a long-term fixed-price power purchase agreement with
Electric Corporation. The project will be generating about 47 gigawatts once operational.
Please turn to the next slide. In this slide, it shows a graph with project timing for completion,
which I have been presenting every quarter for investors to track our project execution.
We have also included aerial photos from our civil works to document the project as shown
the complexity of the site. Unfortunately, like you, I can only enjoy the progress of this massive
project from afar, watching drone videos, aerial photos, and through our weekly project report.
We look forward to be able to go back as soon as Japan opens for foreigners to come back for
business or visitors. I want to take this opportunity to acknowledge the outstanding job
that Toyo Engineering, together with my team, my entrance team, has been able to continue this
project on budget and on time. They have managed a superb engineering project despite COVID
restriction and heavy winter. I'm pleased with their performance. If you go to the next slide,
2014, you can see in graphical form with photos on the extent of the
project. You can see there that a large number of modules have already been installed
and that it's very well advanced on the project. Again, we're very delighted with the progress of
this construction. With that, I would like to turn now the presentation over to our CFO,
Cristian La Puebla. Thank you very much, Marc Antonio.
Moving to slide 16. As we already anticipated in the previous slides, Etron continues to deliver
steady project-level results during this year with our Japanese assets performing well
despite low solar radiation. It all resulted in stable revenue, project-level EBITDA,
and consolidated EBITDA. Our production was down by 4.7% and revenue 2.3%, but on the whole,
project EBITDA was up 1% compared to last year. Our restructuring of our cost base
dropped this result and managed to offset all unfavorable weather conditions.
If you look at full-year cost of EBITDA, it was positively impacted by two elements.
By the sale of the MIE project rights for $33.4 million and by the income we received
for arranging the sale of PV Salvador, which was around $3.3 million.
As a reminder from previous slides, 2020 financials are presented as per FRS 5,
which means that we present assets for healthful sale and discontinued operations.
We started this presentation in Q3 2020. Corporate G&A was affected by the reclassification
from Balanchi to Pinel of accumulated legal and personal costs in connection with the UK
litigation, around $0.7 million, and by the Japanese asset sale transaction expenses of $0.5
million. On the whole, the net income reached $22.5 million, driven mainly by the gain of the
sale of the MIE project income and the income arranging from the sale of PV Salvador.
As a reminder, our Niigata project of 45 MW was approximately 72% completed at the end of Q4
2020 and on track to reach COD by Q4 2021. For more detail on our project level EBITDA in Japan,
you can refer to our financials under the segment note or the MD&A.
Moving to slide 17, as you can see in this slide, ETRON's 57 operational portfolio has
consistently delivered predictable results in terms of revenue and EBITDA, which in turn provide
a steady source of funds. Here is also reflected the benefits of having acquired the HT stake
as we now own 100% of the project and its cash flows.
Moving on to the next slide, slide 18. The two segments, when you look at solar Japan during
2020, the group's Japanese solar access generated revenues of $21.4 million and EBITDA of $16.6
million, which though there was a decrease of $2.3 million, but it read an increase of $0.8
in terms of EBITDA compared to last year. As I said, the optimization of the Japanese corporate
structure and renegotiation of the NM contracts partially offset the impact of lower solar
irrigation levels compared to last year. As a result, it is important to notice the group's
Japanese segment generated a net income of $3 million compared with a net income of $2.1 million
for the same period in 2019. When you look at the corporate segment during this year,
the group's corporate segment generated positive EBITDA of $26.8 million and a net income of $19.5
compared to a negative EBITDA of $2.4 million and a net loss of $6.4 million, respectively,
last year. EBITDA and net results were positively impacted by, again, the gain of the sale of
hedge fund's economic interest in the MIR 60 MW solar project and the income from arranging the
sale of PV Salvador of $3.3 million. On the other side, the company recognized $1.1 million of
unrecoverable withholding taxes triggered by an investment contribution to one of our Japanese
subsidiaries, $0.5 million of tax expense related to the tax assessments received in 2020 in
connection with a prior sale of our Italian assets, and finally, $0.3 million of write-off
expenses related to our wind project. Moving to slide 19.
Erickson has a working capital corporate level of $0.8 million and a conciliated unrestricted
cash position of $8.9 million. After the $46 million of cash belonging to the corporate
segment, $37 million has been transferred to an SO account in order to redeem the corporate bond
on January 7, 2021. This concludes the financial review.
Thank you, Cristian. Before we close the four-year presentation, I would like to highlight
the following messages. Etreon continues to deliver strong financial performance
in all key operating metrics, demonstrating excellent execution in all operational activities.
We're fully funded with no additional capital required to complete the construction of any
other project. We have actually delivered now a company that has no corporate debt.
We manage to expect to reach agreement with the parties to sell substantially all of its assets
by April. Obviously, there's no assurance that this can be a delay, but we are very confident
that we'll be able to deliver the signed agreements with the different parties engaged in
the process of the acquisition of all the assets in Japan. So, with that, I would like to
provide complete our four-year report and back the call to Michelle, our operator,
that would open the call for questions. Thank you.
Thank you. If anybody would like to ask a question, please press star 1 on your telephone
keypad. Again, that would be star 1 on your telephone keypad. Your first question comes from
Martin Middlestad, a private investor. Your line is open. Hi, Marco. I was wondering if you could
elaborate on what the future of the company will be if the Japanese assets are sold as you now
they will be. Thank you, Martin. Great question. As we have outlined, we plan to
present and distribute a large portion of the proceeds upon the completion of the sales of the
project. And within the next...
Over the next four to six weeks, we plan to submit a document to all shareholders, which
we call the Management Information Circular, where we will outline the transactions for
approval and where we will be discussing our plans for distributions and what we're planning
to do. Very likely, we will be distributing most of the cash and one of the main options
of consideration is to wind up the company.
Can you elaborate on what the status of the current tax liabilities are in terms of the
amount and when there might be resolution?
Yeah, so under what we are... Actually, what I'll do is, Cristian, can you maybe ask that
question in terms of how the... from the tax perspective, if you don't mind, please?
What was your question? Is it about tax liabilities regarding Italy or what was your question?
No, there's the tax liability case in Italy that's pending a resolution. I thought there
were claims on that.
Well, it's not a tax liability. It's a tax asset. It's a tax asset. It's in our favor.
Sorry.
That's why I was asking.
Yes. Is that the amount until 11 to 15 and resolution expected this year or next?
This year or next, correct. Yes, we're pending on a court judgment. Exactly.
And is it one case this year and one case next year?
It depends on if there's any appeals. We expect some resolution between Q2 and Q3 this year,
but unfortunately, as you know, COVID delays many things and we don't know
if the judgment will be delayed, but we expect at least a second level judgment at
some times in Q3 and maybe a first level between Q3 and Q4. It all depends on COVID,
but we're positive that we may get an answer this year.
Is the amount still 11 to 15 million euros?
Yes, correct.
And in the other cases that have been brought in these tax cases, have the companies generally
won? I think in a previous conference call, you mentioned that all the cases have been
resolved in favor of the claimants. Is that still the case?
Yes, I think that.
Yes, to our knowledge, all the cases have been favorable for the company.
So going forward, you're going to distribute most of the proceeds to shareholders and then
potentially wind up the company pending the resolution of these tax cases. Is that a fair
summation?
Correct.
I mean, so if there was some potential upside, we would obviously maintain those and
those would be then distributed, the net proceeds as well.
All right, great. Those are all the questions I had. Thank you.
Thank you, Martin.
Again, if anybody would like to ask a question, please press star one on your telephone keypad.
That would be star one on your telephone keypad.
I have no further questions at this time. I turn the call back over to our presenters
for closing remarks.
Thank you for joining the 2020 Operational Finance Call and we look forward to updating you
on our progress in the months ahead. Thank you and have a great day. Thank you.
Thank you, everyone. This will conclude today's conference call. You may now disconnect.